copying okay so he's gonna e4 again
i don't think i'll just willy-nilly
enter the italian again looks like he
was
he knew this that stuff too well and
he's very showing those maneuvering
positions where he has a space advantage
oh
speaking of maneuvering positions as
where you have a space at that that you
don't get any of those in the caribou
yes
but um i'll give it something else at
the very least
okay um would be good if i had a plan of
what to do here
but i don't so
there you go
i mean i did play c5 here many years ago
against korea
i think 10 years ago in romania but
oh well i'll try
try something else
c
clearly he knows this stuff better than
i do
now i think you go knight b3
then c5 believe that is his idea
then knight c8
this is something that uh
i think topolov did
many years ago
at least i think i saw it in the game
with this
i thought it was pretty cool basic idea
of
rerouting the knight anywhere is that
is that uh um
that e7 is usually the best square for
both the knight and the bishop and you
can only place one of your pieces there
so you have to get creative about
where to put the other one
um i think i'll go hp7
i'm not sure i should be fearing this
although i am
of course fearing aids
that's a very obscure reference
anyway um i hope to
be able to go um knight of faith and
then
96 blockade but
he might have something violent here
like queen d3
and g6 and then
e6 takes rookie one
king f7 queen h2 knight if
oh he goes for e6 immediately
maybe that's even better but my
intuition serve told me that he should
have
provoked
you should have provoked um
uh g6 as well
okay this could be this could get ugly
but for the moment i'm sort of
sticking to my guns and taking taking
pawns
yeah i really want to go queen c8 here
i'm allowing b3
knight d6 knight e5 kj it could
end up not being that terrible okay i'll
do it
for the walls
i mean comparing
comparing to what i had in the first
game at three at least i'm upon off
but there's no denying that he has a
great compensation
for the pawn here it's probably it's
probably just better
yeah this smooth is annoying
smoke is certainly annoying
you know what i've weakened my position
so much already
what is one more
[Music]
this move is annoying i missed that one
yeah i was thinking bishop e5 knight
rook h7 um
and then probably b3 i'll take it and
now i'm just getting at best the much
worse
version of that okay so he just takes it
it's a bit surprising check
okay we'll go where do
i think probably g7
don't love it
and we'll take and take an e5
what choices they're really made had to
be prevented but now
if he takes everything and takes an e6
there is fortunately
gonna be a background mate which may
alleviate some of my most immediate
issues
the fact that there is background mate
if knight d3 i'll go knight g6
and one of my pieces is on a decent
square
which is basically the crown achievement
of my game so far so we can go like
rookie 3
win d7 now probably g3 followed by h4
damn it now i fall for the cheapo
ugh ugh no
no if i don't like rook
no i'm still pretty bad it's probably
a lot worse than it looks
i mean i thought i had my best position
in a long time when just
protecting everything and um
more or less fine positionally speaking
that is
that is annoying
i guess not
aha yes
managed to find the one thing
literally the only way that
can win the position
yeah see that's one thing i'm good at
finding all these one move tricks
uh but magnus is deep tricks and i see
them one more ticks